[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin et en
direct de la belle ville de marseille
bons journaux missonnier merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous président de la région
sud provence alpes côte d'azur on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice veysseyre dont du groupe ebra
question aux présidents des régions de
france aussi renaud muselier jean castex
et un élu local un homme qui emploie le
mot territoire à de nombreuses reprises
depuis qu'il a été nommé à matignon est
ce que pour vous c'est un bon signal
tout à fait c'est un élu local maire
d'occitanie ancien conseiller régional
il a déjà plusieurs casquettes important
dans sa formation de base c'est que
coller parfaitement et broie centrale
connaît parfaitement administration
coller parfaitement la décentralisation
a le rôle des acteurs locaux et je pense
que dans le cadre de la confiance que
nos gouvernants doit porter au
territoire
c'est un homme qui peut-être nous a
tenté de répondre en question est en
tout cas nous sommes attendus
est ce qu'il vous a déjà contacté en
tant que président des régions de france
renaud muselier
oui je lui samedi soir au téléphone et
donc on a évoqué à ce sujet donc bien
sûr le travail avec les régions qu'est
ce qu'il vous a dit bon je les félicite
et dans un premier temps je lui
rappelais que nous avons une réunion
avec les clans de région juste l'après
midi de sa nomination que la globalité
des taux une région seront plutôt
heureux de le voir arriver que pour nous
c'est la possibilité avec un territoire
qui en fait c'est à dire monsieur
d'avoir lé maire monsieur bussereau et
les départements et nous fait en sorte
que au delà la démarche a été faite par
le président du sénat qui a présenté au
président de la république c'est 50
propositions nous écrivons dans cette
logique où nous voulons avoir la
capacité d'aider notre pays en fonction
des compétences qui sont les nôtres
elles sont grandes multiples il faut
simplement vous faire confiance je vais
vous poser la question directement tout
de suite comme ça on sera fixé un vous
l'avez eue au téléphone maintenant
circulent pour rentrer au gouvernement
est ce qu'il vous la proposer en tout
cas je n'en ferai pas donc voilà ça le
problème est réglé mon nom circule comme
vous avez chaussures souvent mais j'aime
bien expérience aussi un quand on envoie
le nom en pâture c'est qu'en général il
ne sort jamais donc les dotations
suppression de régions je suis très
heureux chez moi et présidents des
régions de france et je crois que je
peux faire beaucoup de choses que mon
pays et je démens gouverne au gros si tu
n'es pas l'oublier d'ailleurs mais en
tout cas mon pays dans le cadre de
décisions qui ont sorte que les
territoires et les eaux seront utiles
pour la suite on a les qualités à venir
entre ray pas mais est ce que ça vous a
été proposé aux nommés et les non je ne
m'a pas été paul va revenir aux
questions des territoires des lions oui
une question rejoint visionner une
question un homme du sud que vous êtes
l'accent de jean castex a été moquée ces
dernières heures beaucoup commentée sur
les réseaux sociaux
ça dit quelque chose de la france de
2020 ce nombre il dit est de ceux qui
sont donc de la force des territoires
non quand j'entends jean castex déjà
autant l'avoir rugueuse et rocailleux
des joueurs de rugby du sud ouest et ça
c'est toujours quelque chose qui vous
plaît beaucoup et puis moi qui suis
peut-être par les accents souvent du fil
et ce alors par contre la salle urmatt
herman tellement moquer de moi de mon
sourire elle n'empêche pas comme un
cerveau bolat et les études et qu'on a
une compétence avec une certaine
distance mais taxe sera tourné à tout
votre soutien ce matin me coûter en tout
cas je suis tend la main vous savez il
encore une position très difficile
d'abord je soutiens fin je salue le
travail qui a été fait par le premier
ministre qui dans cette crise l'affairé
l'ancien monsieur leur physique qui a
fait beaucoup de choses dans cette crise
bon ben maintenant on passe dans une
nouvelle étape a demandé au président de
la république est ce que cette étape
sera une valable pour votre pays et
efficaces pour nos concitoyens par l
intermédiaire des collectivités s'ils
ont compris ça on aura beaucoup avancé
justement puisque vous parlez d'edouard
philippe à ce que le fait que jean
castex arrive à matignon ça augure d'une
nouvelle relation entre l'exécutif et
les régions notamment et puis les
associations d'élus plus largement
ou est ce que le problème ce n'était pas
edouard philippe c'était emmanuel macron
il vous craignez que rien ne change
août est de toute façon c'est la
république éric lavigne premier ministre
il applique
nous avons eu des destinées situation
très très difficile avec eux dans la
république et son gouvernement
jusqu'à fin 2019 nous sommes partis sur
de bonnes bases début 2020 ces bases
nous ont permis dans le cadre de la
crise de prendre de l'air est
redoutablement efficace à mon avis sur
le plan de la crise sanitaire comme sur
le plan de l'aide économique au goût à
la norme dans le cas de cette crise pan
c'est pour moi maintenant on a un
nouveau premier ministre
on va voir tout de suite se dire 14
juillet avec des propos publics et la
démarche des premiers ministres derrière
comment il veut nous était bon on est
toujours avec la main tant mieux c'est
ce qu'on va faire et d'ailleurs on
présentera mercredi une conférence de
presse avec eux les trois présidents des
grandes associations pour bien demandé à
appeler pour être la place de chacun
dans ce pays dans l'application la loi
dans la clarification des compétences et
dans la confiance justement un mercredi
à vous le disiez conférence de presse de
territoire et unir l'association qui
regroupe l'association des maires de
france des départements et vous régions
de france
quel va être le message plus précisément
pour le message il et qui paye décide et
qui a fini avec la clarification des
compétences
le travail de merde t'as pas la même
chose que l'aménagement d'un territoire
par un parent par une région auxi mythe
et / ou sanitaires et sociales par
exemple médico-social exactement poulet
pour les départements on est très en
phase tous les trois présidents et donc
on devrait présenter une proposition
claire précise et unifiée pour le
gouvernement et j'espère que monsieur le
premier ministre en cas braquage qui va
dire quoi précisément renaud muselier la
proximité immédiate pour les mairies
l'intermédiaire pour les départements
l'aménagement des territoires pour les
régions je sois cette équipe en
entonnant des paroles économisent pour
l'épreuve pour l'interurbain
pour tout ce qui est l'environnemental
aussi d'ailleurs on a chacun nos
compétences de proximité et on a bien vu
d'ailleurs dans la crise du coc vide que
ses compétences sans boiter j'en suis là
c'est bien mais c'est quoi ces clarifier
les compétences pour chaque niveau de
collectivité ou s'est demandé plus de
compétences déjà c'est qu'on clarifie
les compétences c'est déjà bien
et de l'appeler dans ses compétences il
ne faut pas que ça sur les taxes des
charges sur nous pour vous en donner les
moyens
exemple simple pour le sanitaire
monségur
nous faisons des propositions pour la
présidence de la rs parler puis le prix
tant les régions de france pour
l'organisation des déserts médicaux qui
préside piloté par la région et les
hôpitaux directement aux autocars la
proximité dans les communes
mais ceux-ci s'aménage sur une somme
territoriale et n'a pas vu par nationale
où on peut pas traiter les nationales
dans une région comme la mienne
l'hôpital de briançon la même manière
que le chu de marseille vous qui à
l'instant la question budgétaire qui
paye commande qui paye décide
est-ce que compte tenu de la situation
c'est le bon moment pour demander de
l'argent à l'état nous on ne demande pas
de l'argent ne vont que nous en prennent
plus j'ai quand vous tente en vain par
exemple l'année dernière nous a repris
l'apprentissage et ses partisans dans le
schéma national
et bien aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation compliquée parce que du
national avec france compétences puisque
la totalité de l'apprentissage est et
repris par france compétences bien
comment voulez vous qu'ils traitent une
école d'esthéticienne et le gac le brio
son vassal bushiste du national et donc
on se retrouve dans un schéma où il
enroule recentraliser reconcentrer alors
que nous voulons déconcentrées et
décentralisées
je vous donne un exemple très simple
nous sommes nous avons un passage très
important à ce moment avec la
négociation des fonds européens
21 27 40 milliards d'euros qui vont sur
la france et nous sommes en possibilité
du jeune homme nie tout et de gestion
est-ce que nous allemands français va
nous faire confiance pour en gérer tout
ou partie vous avez aimé les grillons
muselier vous estimez que l'état a
compensé les compétences qui vous a
transféré budgétairement le qu'antillais
aujourd'hui ah non non quand il est pas
du tout ils ont rempli des compétences
et nous enlever les moyens financiers et
d'autre part ils nous ont confié des
actions pour autant ils ne peuvent pas
mener
en fait qu'il ya dans lequel ils ont
donné aucun moyen complémentaire
c'est la volonté j'étais en train de
dire lever des fonds européens
aujourd'hui vous avez les feux verticaux
qui leur permettent c'est à dire le
projet sur l'aéronautique le plan
tourisme et aux moyens financièrement
dizaines de milliards d'euros qui
doivent traîner sur le territoire pour
airbus publicitaire pour l'année mais
voilà toutes nos industries qui ont été
directement impactés et donc comment
arriver au plus près du sous traitant
pour qu'il n'y ait pas des filières un
casque à quito la presse avait le combo
les contrats de plan état région qui
doivent être traités maintenant va votre
signer maintenant dans le cas de la
relance
impossible à cydia et en mettant en
perspective sur les antilles pas un
minimum de ressources s'il est un cas
aujourd'hui donc c'est un moment
historique a lancé un nouveau premier
ministre
nouvelle position en vue des territoires
vous allez les fonds européens hauteur
de 40 milliards dizaines de milliards
d'euros dans différents plans
structurels qui vont venir sur nos
territoires et en même temps le contrat
de plan a signé et donc on va voir s'il
va nous faire confiance aux moments
importants sur la question de la
décentralisation interrogé hier dans le
journal du dimanche jean castex ne
répond pas vraiment il dit l'état peut
aussi exister sur les territoires et
mais il peut faire mieux en faisant
autrement comment vous avez compris sa
réponse sur la décentralisation comme
toujours c'est que c'est le merdier
plein ou à moitié vide
nous on a l'impression qu'à ses sables
et a fixé le cadre et le car est le même
pour toutes à france mais à l'intérieur
du car il ya des moyens d'action qui
sont est très important les différents
le traitement des 2e vide une fois des
hommes de lignes sncf sur le territoire
n'a rien à voir dans le centre s'emballe
de noirs dans la région provinces et
régions nous sommes contraints dans nos
montagnes
le trade plan de l'aménagement du
territoire du grand test où il ya plus
de demandes métropole n'a rien à voir
avec le traitement en nouvelles
aquitaine donc chaque région les
différences c'est la force de notre de
notre région notre pays et nous avons la
taille critique me semble-t-il pour bien
organiser tout ça est de structurer
d'où l'importance du cadre national qui
fixe la loi et des différenciations avec
la décentralisation qui fera
l'efficacité s'y croit
et encore à ce nouvel acte de
décentralisation est ce que par exemple
vous continuez à travailler avec
jacqueline gourault sur la fameuse loi
3d oui mais avec les troisièmes je
savais que je l'avais dit avoir détrôné
pour les 3 c il faut confiance car tes
compétences dans le cadre de la crise on
a retrouvé une partie de la confiance
qu'on avait bien perdu la clarté sur un
certain nombre de domaines la confiance
relative quand même malgré tout sur les
compétences qui ont été les nôtres
d'autant plus qu'il ya une sorte de
critiques qui ont été faites dans la
cadre d'un crise sanitaire et la demande
les régions étaient là pour venez pour
venir épauler le gouvernement dans son
interview à la presse quotidienne
régionale emmanuel macron parle d'un
retour de la conférence des territoires
est ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
idée si c'est pour leur offrir comme la
dernière c'était pas la peine d'aller
cité de l'amour ovale amoureux qui le
somme remarquable on a une très bonne
relation avec elle mais à la sortie de
l'arbitrage même s'il est en parlant
d'elle donc si on veut la garder comme
interlocutrice ne fasse aura ce qu'est
les arbitrages favorables aux eaux
territoriales ce serait très bien
parallèlement à ça est ce que c'est une
bonne idée vous savez à la fois c'était
une boîte d'enregistrement il est il
donc si c'est pour remettre en place une
boîte d'enregistrement ils n'utilisent
pas appel ce qui si on peut la refonder
la retravailler la remette en place de
façon à ce que cela soit efficace
si donc ces lignes m le travail des
commissions lors d'actes certainement
rien c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
embêter renforce clairement il ya des
conditions pour que veut participer à
une nouvelle conférence des territoires
si elle a lieu on ne compte pas
condition de l'efficacité
donc voilà les conditions salut d'accès
une forme de menace on va pas perdre
notre temps pour discuter pendant des
heures alors qu'ils ont c'est exactement
ce que nous proposons ce qu'il propose
que l'on peut faire ce que l'on peut
faire progressivement
ils veulent ne veulent pas si c'est pour
se retrouver autour d'une table et
discuter pendant des heures pour
divaguer moi je préfère cillé et a
marché dans quelques jours 14 juillet le
président de la république va s'exprimer
vous attendez à un cap de sa part je
crois que tous les français attendent un
cap on se retrouve au lendemain
d'élections municipales au lendemain
d'une crise
ovide en fait on a aujourd'hui trees on
sort d'une crise sanitaire
je fais encore attention ça sera bien
regarder derrière nous on a une crise
économique majeure qui a été plutôt très
bien traité par le gouvernement pendant
ses intérêts avec les régions de france
on a devant nous une crise sociale et je
crois que je suis pas sûr qu'ils
réalisent à quel point ça va être un
tsunami difficulté qui arrive dans cette
caisse sociale et il ne faut pas de
crise politique derrière nous la région
de france on s'est toujours risqué dans
cette démarche et on veut patrice
politique mais on veut des solutions à
nos problèmes et peut-être que le
prenant la république apportera les
grandes pistes pour ses solutions à
mettre en oeuvre par son gouvernement
cette même interview à la presse
quotidien régional emmanuel macron la
semaine dernière averti pourtant la
rentrée va être très difficile va être
très dur néanmoins son premier ministre
annonce déjà la rouverture de la réforme
des retraites
c'est une bonne chose selon vous il ya
beaucoup de chantiers ouvrir au ministre
le sujet anciens et je crois non ou est
ce un sujet anciens sujets à venir
surtout le travail de moins en moins de
moins en moins longtemps on dépense le
plus d'argent dans le cas d'une crise du
coup ville où on voit quand même des
milliards de roy réduire vous nos mini
short et en même temps il ya cette crise
endémique des retraites qui n'a jamais
été prêté alors est-ce que je l'avais
abordée par le bon bout à dernière fois
la preuve est faite que non ce qu'il
faut aussi remettre mais c'est pas parce
que c'est difficile
donc si on a un nom renaud muselier sur
ce rapport au vitriol en des sapeurs
pompiers qui sur la gestion de de la
crise sanitaire c'est leur retour
d'expérience qui parle de
désorganisation de trop fort poids de la
bureaucratie
est-ce que vous c'est ce que vous avez
constaté et est-ce qu'il faut mettre fin
aux agences régionales de santé
non mais il fonctionne assez bien on se
prend très bien la difficulté c'est que
je voyais mes collègues des déserts de
région il ya des ars qui ont été
complètement inefficace sa part été les
cas dans la région sud lorsque les ars
de la région ont diminué leur moyenne
aucun contact 1 et département et se
sont re se réaliser sous l'autorité
nationale et ne répond qu'au jour de la
civilité du gouvernement enfin de
l'autorité de tutelle du ministre la
santé et n'ont plus les moyens c'est
aussi bien de la limite de l'exercice de
moulins au nord
et c'est que avoue blanc n'ont pas les
moyens d'appliquer leurs décisions
nationales alors que au niveau local a
la possibilité de faire de là l'idée de
personne que les présidents de région
soit cohésion d éloges sur la crise
sanitaire par oublier marseille les
marins pompiers ont remarquablement
travaillé donc on n'a pas eu trop de
difficulté mais les terres comme le
jardin qui connais bien qui est qui et
qui d'ailleurs il riche tissu qui a émis
ce rapport en tout cas lui ses réserves
il a parfaitement raison de ces trois
crises sanitaires toutes sortes de délai
fulguration et de dysfonctionnements
c'est la raison pour laquelle des deux
assemblées a formé le sénat sur la la la
la la commission maquette il ya des
choses qui ont dysfonctionné de façon
majeure et avec une issue à la santé on
est un état dans l'état
ils votent pour centraliser et ils font
confiance à personne forcément vous
demandant quand il ya urgence il ya une
crise il n'y arrive pas allez on va
parler marseillais va parler des
municipales à marseille
et pour commencer c'est guilhem
brickaville le directeur des rédactions
du groupe la provence qui va vous poser
la question oui bonjour bonjour à tous
dont jour renaud muselier
on a suivi cette folle journée bien
samedi à marseille 1 6 heures de conseil
municipal avec des coups de théâtre le
candidat du rassemblement national qui a
quitté l'hémicycle avant même le début
du vote avec des tractations beaucoup de
tension aussi pour cette succession de
jean claude gaudin et à l'arrivée on a
donc vu cette victoire de michele ruby
rôle à moi j'avais une question c'est
est ce que la droite ne paie pas au prix
fort à marseille le prix de ses
divisions
et est ce que ces divisions renaud
muselier ne sont pas le fait peut-être
de l'absence j'allais dire d'un chef de
file
le légitime pour gérer la droite à
marseille bonjour monsieur récamier la
séance du conseil municipal plus
consternante d'une part ya les vues et
systématique pour tous les élus de
marseille venus du pointon marseille
vis-à-vis des autres que je trouve tout
à fait l'idée quand on veut respecter
l'environnement général la démocratie en
particulier
on doit respecter ses élus sur le volet
et de ses sujets soutient pas le rsa une
région où ce pape est très dans les
histoires ont pu finir c'était c'était
consternant ce qui s'est passé et ils
n'ont pas participé à ces tractations
qui était consternant 7 pour marseille
et on était la risée de la france
entière tous à la naissance à l'issue
nous avons aujourd'hui une mère et je
suis heureux de savoir que la majorité
une majorité de 51 de la possibilité de
gouverner
c'était une chose qui était prioritaire
à mes yeux ce qui concerne la droite
ça fait longtemps que je dis que c'est
ce qu'a bien arthur zopa bull sait ce
que veut la rupture ni soumises souley
l'encourager du maire sortant qui ne
travaillait plus et qu'il utilisait à
mener tranquillement au désastre à
commencer par son propre secteur dans
son propre secteur
donc tout ça c'est en sorte il faut
maintenant construire ce qui est
important c'est maintenant que va-t-il
se passer à dans les échéances à venir
notamment la métropole
moi je dirais pour madame giroux là
quand je regarde qui se confie sur le la
campagne toute personne n'y a pas eu
débat qui n'a pas mérité un des marques
absolument incroyable
le peintre marseille vient d'être élu
sur le fond cela peut concerner que
c'est plutôt la victoire d'il y'a qu'à
faut qu'on
on n'a jamais parlé des moyens
financiers de l'organisation avec les
autres collectivités
que ce soit le département la métropole
la région l'état et l'europe
on a vu
promesse sur les écoles à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros oui l'argent lorsqu'il
concerne simplement qu'un environnement
moi je regarde pourra s'opposer à la
région avec la corse
ils ont un train de retard donc tout ça
fait en sorte qu' ils sont dedans dans
une situation financière difficile parce
que l'or à l'étagé compliqué ils doivent
se projeter dans l'avenir et on sait pas
comment cette année qui par exemple avec
eux ils veulent donner envie de
travailler au aux employés municipaux
ça c'est gentil décalé l'utap a remis le
soir par exemple ici peau mais c'est pas
une commande tactiquement avec les
différents syndicats en place avec des
cadres qui sont souvent l'inaugurant a
eu très souvent démonétisé donc donc
beaucoup de chantiers où l'économique
une ville qui la met villes métropoles
de la région la ville capitale de
l'argent vous nous dites vous ne dites
beaucoup de choses on va essayer de
reprendre un peu d'abord pour pour faire
suite à elle à la question de guilhem
est ce que quand même vous vous sentez
en partie responsable du naufrage de la
droite marseillaise
bah écoutez donc partis à partir donc
comme mon grand père c'est sur votre
chaîne que j'ai dit que la buzzer y
avait deux mandats de trop quand même
j'ai dit qu'il fallait d'aller plus loin
il s'adonne au niveau régional j'ai fait
le pacte régional
le pacte régional on a gagné toutes les
villes du département et de la région
on a 75 % des villes de la région qui
s'inscrit dans la politique régionale
on a gagné les gars dan ar la section
mes nerfs ne font n'a pas dansé dans la
base d'étain campagne que j'ai fait dans
l'organisation
ça n'a pas été suivi à marseille j'ai
demandé le parc de raisons mais annie
elles n'ont jamais réussi à s'entendre
sur le sur le fond comme sur la forme
ben voilà où ça les mène et c'est
maintenant que ça veut dire clairement
ça veut dire clairement que vous rejetez
toujours la responsabilité de ce qui
s'est passé sur jean claude gaudin il a
mal préparé sa succession est ce cette
campagne d ni fait ni à faire
la responsabilité de jean claude gaudin
est évidente le fait que martine vassal
à l'origine n'est pas plus longtemps
d'avoir laissé bruno gilles se
présentait contre matthew personnes dans
le même secteur que madame au bureau la
kia cup data la mairie c'est une
conscience politique
l'agressivité permanente n'est pas un
moment de campagne
donc les extraits le système les excès
tout ça c'est jamais bon il faut arriver
à avoir une des candidatures les
campagne apaisée
non bien sûr le flou avec une vision
avec une organisation l'a pas eu
vous nous présenter cet échec complet
problème est très doctement je pense que
quand même c'est pas une bonne chose
tout ça pour pour marseille et quand
même à cette heure vous nous présenter
quand même une vision assez
apocalyptique de la situation de la
ville une situation politique économique
etc
d'ailleurs c'est l'héritage du passé
mais mes amis n'ont pas jamais vendu
faire le bilan pour arriver ils sont
restés dans le délit de la situation et
dans laquelle nous sommes
le printemps marseillais a su en
profiter vous faire mal à mounir aulas
n'a jamais eu de responsabilité
importante dans son équipe il ya peu
d'expérience donc des on voit bien qu'il
n'ya pas d'expérience comment ça
fonctionne je n'ai j'ai entendu beaucoup
de bêtises dans le cadre de la campagne
où on a mélangé toutes les compétences
toutes les organisations toutes les
structures et ceci sans aucun moyen
financier
bon donc il faut remettre de l'ordre
d'ailleurs j'espère qu'elle sera capable
de le faire au niveau financier dans la
ville of honey organisationnel me
fatigue au niveau politique et il ya peu
de
personnalités qui ont eu des
responsabilités dans une ville comme
marseille aussi dur aussi compliqué
aussi complète la bonne volonté et pas
toujours suffisante
ça veut dire et ce sera la dernière
question vous êtes inquiet pour l'avenir
de marseille aujourd'hui je suis très
inquiet pour l'engrais marseille je suis
très inquiet quand je vois le programme
tel qu'il est présenté
je suis inquiet je suis rassurée par le
fait qu'il ya une majorité parce que ça
c'est indispensable dans une ville
difficile et de notation comme je le dis
dans le communiqué le miel dès
l'élection d'amir là je prêterai
marseille avec l'attention qu'elle
mérite
et d'ailleurs nous allons engager avec
le maire précédent projet de 40 millions
de blu sur toute une série de dossiers
qui sont à disposition
ceci dans son regard dans la ville mais
il faut qu'ils sachent les monter les
dossiers de travail et partager les
compétences
certains d'entre eux sur les objectifs
et aujourd'hui dans le cadre du
programme que j'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'attention
oui je suis inquiet merci beaucoup merci
renaud muselier d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin en direct depuis marseille merci à
guilhem herick avis également qu'on
trouve un petit peu plus tard dans cette
émission
merci fabrice veysseyre dont et on se
retrouve tout de suite le club des
territoires